welcome to this video playing Dominator
from the Ukraine but right now is not
dominating his waiting while doing
nothing don't know is playing a move on
that so maybe maybe go for the tango
here is a grandmaster it always needs
takes a while to to get the title
information he has played this rather
uncommon d5 news check check
mostly and this isn't considered so
dangerous because white um yeah what
exposes the center a bit and it's it's
it's not so well supported
yeah I'm getting quick counterplay here
in the center but it's got the G file so
it's possible that he's going for some
play on the default so what now
I can I can take on d5
twice
this is the the kind of easy solution
that it's I don't like it so much let's
just get the other pieces developed
maybe this is an idea
attacking c3 and d5
oh I didn't see that move what if I SiC
the Queen Queen c3 Bishop takes Bishop
takes check King moves Bishop a one
Queen a one at the end that's the
pressure on g7 oh I am this is why it's
not working but wait if I if I sacked
the Queen and I don't take the rook as
this may be an idea he needs to go to
you too
okay
check so if the queen is not able to to
activate yourself quickly no maybe moves
like that you know it's just two pieces
but I don't know 95 95 was Mary but
Bishop age 7 okay I but he I cannot take
okay I have I'm having many ideas at the
same time this was one idea Knight f4
Bishop g4 yeah I don't know maybe this
is this the sacrifices complete bogus
but I think it's interesting though here
cannot go f3 oh I can actually consider
ruk ruk III I can consider takes Knight
takes but he might take here let's do
this first
isn't this cocky no I didn't see that
move at all I am and I'm not sure what
it is doing okay
he wants to go Queen d3 and then take on
c3 so I probably better move the king
right so he doesn't he doesn't have a
temple
so I better move the bishop or not this
is also in a strange spot
what the hell
quite a karate position
yeah I keep overlooking a museum this is
not good didn't see see the scissors
this means
yeah no it's it's gone now it's gone I
don't have the peace coordination
necessary for this to work I think the
sacrifice was pretty interesting at
first this is this is now just a win for
white
that's not it's not completely easy but
it is a win
time warning yeah I have no moves
and I could also just resign I mean how
am I going to ever make the child
control they're not yeah yeah black
resigns yeah assembly lost lost the
threat him okay the couple of +5 so my
sacrificial idea is basically nonsense
yeah but it was so clear yeah maybe it
was I thought that maybe is some some
play but yeah okay I still I'm amazed
that it is a +5 I mean I've got two
pieces it's not what yeah okay it's not
enough I thought them they might might
be something but the compass is
basically telling me I'm lost check this
is of course a good news I probably this
wasn't the only one there are some ideas
let's say like this this is what I saw
for example but okay Bishop h7 was so
strong so all in all this was not
working